hey party people in the town touching
their own faces this is our TGIF that's
just the no teller touching our own
faces nice actually it's really bad for
skin okay I saw that okay
hi guys hi guys all right hi guys I'm
here with Hannah Hart from my heart to
your heart semi drunk kitchen
hello harto my drunk kitchen a guide to
going something something going with
your gut right all the above and more
we're currently in Vancouver we're
working on an adventure than I can't and
she can't talk about just yet which is
why friary
again has been postponed this week
however we think we came up with a
really fun alternative to showing you
Friday or you say anything challenge is
formally done by Miranda sings and
memorize name ray its two syllables and
the hand we may mark right right
basically the challenge is you say
anything we each take turns saying
anything and then if one of us doesn't
say something or stutters or something
like that then we take tape and we do
terrible things to each other's faces I
mean like writing starting off pretty
low in the facial Department oh speaking
on behalf of only myself here's the tape
how long are we doing this and I don't
know but I'm sweaty
sure no I can't like what if I lose
because I'm a hot you start Apple bucket
duck
remote cherry cranberry day a [ __ ] okay
listen I'm gonna clean cabinet book
avocado shell banana our chair great
foot for and cleaning tissue lots tuna
melts books now like cubic like ships
NHL tackle yeah i'm won't be the tape at
all
this is my good I liked you before take
today
singer wise microphone a is very too fun
for adventure six I'm anything a so me
don't I you ego agree you can't like my
knobhead you just lost Oh God are you so
oh how can you breathe yes yeah here's a
new rule you can't say a sentence you
have to say words how can you know you
can't like a man named about it but the
Beagle matter it's two words I and I
said both of them that's better I could
just die do you lose
nah there's not that many parts of a
face uh you'd be surprised what Cape can
do to it
is that weird ha ha ha this is me just
like really angrily flirting with
somebody yeah okay yeah okay that's
roots are broccoli sorry
ah like or just unabashedly easygoing on
you today just getting me over faceless
do you neutral resting face
oh it tap Oh Oh giggles you Michael
you get all your giggle is the final
round I think lash oh you're done you're
not like a song girl well we did say
anything challenge chatter horse you
ever dissipate if anything this proves
the traditional media that new media is
taking over lays ahead providing content
that really changes the world and makes
a difference I think so I think now it's
like that new show Sexy's
are you guys a sexy piece that's it is
it exactly saying one day one of us is
gonna get bad last accessory Holly boy
you can't tell but I'm shocked by go
check out his channel for a hilarious
drunk kitchen shenanigans subscribe to
our channel for more adventures I will
tell you about our adventures soon Hosea
Vanda I don't know I seriously don't
know what you just said